hi I'm Deadpool the other jolly guy in a
red suit with a Lapworth sitting on here
to tell you happy holidays in the spirit
of this most festive time of year I've
decided to release my holiday cheer all
over the world so sit back hold on your
ornaments
ghazal a little eggnog at least that
looks like eggnog and prepare yourself
because it's time for Saint Wade to put
the wind in winter wonderland happy
holidays everybody the Deadpool to
marketing campaign has started and just
like last year they're doing is many
ridiculous things as possible you
probably remember all the Christmas
stuff they did that was just the
beginning like the 12 days of Deadpool
they also did a bunch of crazy Halloween
stuff there was the Mario Lopez promo
where he literally punched him right out
of his chair Slater April Fool's
Deadpool will of course be rated R it's
ok Jessie Slater can't hurt you anymore
the big difference this year is the
Deadpool isn't coming out in February
it's coming out in June so the marketing
campaign has just started a little bit
later if you're just finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
it'll be a lot like when we were getting
ready for the first Deadpool movie
during the holidays with all that funny
stuff that dropped and I'll be doing
giveaway stuff for the Deadpool movie
too so I'll explain that at the end of
the video by this time last year we'd
already gotten the first couple of
Deadpool trailers so what they've done
is they've sent out some select issues
of a Good Housekeeping magazine with
Deadpool on the cover just hyping up how
to cook your Thanksgiving turkey and all
these good housekeeping tips like you
see this poster here with the main
actors you even see a Stan Lee cameo in
the background here the way they're
explaining it is that you can't go out
and buy this issue like they literally
took it to a bunch of press outlets and
a bunch of people but they actually took
it one step further and had it written
as if Deadpool were writing this big
feature about how to carve your turkey
so there's a little too much text for me
to read it like it would literally take
me 20 minutes to read all the stuff he's
written so I'll just read the intro and
explain what the other pages are but you
see on the cover
Deadpool stuffs our holiday issue how to
be a holiday superhero you'll go crazy
for
deez nutz giving your family the bird
Turkey tips come for the gifts stay for
the package as it you know just making
as many jokes as possible the letter
reads a Wade with words
Deadpool's holiday letter dear readers
skimmers and those who generally only
look at the pictures
when Good Housekeeping called and asked
me to be a contributor to their holiday
issue I was completely shocked and
flattered I'm a huge fan it's always
been a dream of mine to visit the Good
Housekeeping mansion and bathe in their
infamous grotto there's a joke about the
Playboy Mansion because they have a
grotto where a bunch of naked people
just hang out all the time but unlike
most men I read Good Housekeeping for
the articles
like another big Playboy joke there was
no time to waste
I immediately jumped off my show pony
kiss my agent Bernie and grabbed my ink
quill in case you weren't aware I
freaking love the holidays and not in
the like a friend way either I love the
holidays in the same way I love stuffing
a turkey using the two most important
ingredients of all heavy eye contact and
lust
it's that bewitching time of year where
we can reflect on the last 11 months
using Christmas cards from friends and
family is a comparable gauge of our own
levels of happiness Stephanie and Adam
went to Palm Springs
Janet finally got her GED uncle Kevin
drank a gallon of sangria took off all
his clothes and walked into the ocean
forever but whether your Yuletide
memories are of gorging on nuts and
creamy clams see my holiday recipes
getting your tongue stuck to the
flagpole or simply watching papa pool
carve some perfectly plump poultry in
order to give everyone the bird there's
no denying that the holidays are the
most wonderful time of year so sit back
grab a mug of cocoa and cozy up in your
favorite chair it's time for this
naughty little stocking stuffer to
unleash his holiday cheer
xoxo Wade so that's just him letting you
know that the Deadpool - promotional
campaign has begun like we're gonna
start getting trailers and teasers
throughout the rest of the year but it
is funny to see the level of detail that
they go into with some of this marketing
like there's actually a lot of thought
that goes into this so they actually do
have instructions for how to carve a
turkey were you basically why
cutting off a bunch of your limbs like
you can see him slowly carving the
turkey up he accidentally cuts off a
couple of his fingers like down here it
says by now your turkeys torso should
resemble middle of the movie lieutenant
dan if you guys haven't seen Forrest
Gump he basically has no legs which
means it's time to clip your beautiful
bird's wings like a Pegasus at the glue
factory so just like we did before
find the wing joint poppet slice
separate and bam
nice work Emeril so really like all
these different instructions they're all
just metaphors for sex it's just the way
that Deadpool would turn everything into
an innuendo the funny thing about deez
nutz and creamy clams skinny dip is that
they do have legit recipes so I'm gonna
clip these out and paste them here you
can pause the video if you want to copy
these recipes down because you can
actually make these eat the nuts and
drink the cream make as many jokes as
you can about eating Deadpool spiced
nuts and drinking his creamy clam skinny
dip but just to be clear even though
they're trying to be really funny about
giving him a these are actually
legit recipes that you can make but let
me know in the comments what do you guys
think about all this obviously this is
just tipping the hat to the crazy stuff
they're gonna be doing this year it'll
be just like last year if you remember
all the weird promos that they did they
did prostate exams they did a pool log
during Christmas like it was literally
just hours and hours of Deadpool with a
log but the big difference this year is
that we have cable so they might work
him into some of these funny promotions
too and then beyond all the funny stuff
there's the regular trailers and teasers
so those will drop between now in the
end of the year now the main reason why
they're doing this is a Thanksgiving
issue is is because Thanksgiving is
getting ready to come up in the United
States but they might also release a
trailer in the next couple of weeks too
because we have Star Wars coming so they
might try to attach the next big trailer
to Star Wars when it comes out in
December or before the end of the year
but there'll be other stuff beyond the
regular trailer too
so if you were subscribed to me way back
when Deadpool was being promoted like
two years ago around this time it'll
probably be a little bit like that but
because the movie is a little further
out they might not release quite as much
marketing
but I think they're gonna try and take
advantage of the holidays at the end of
the year because there's already gonna
be a bunch of big stuff happening
between this and Star Wars leave all
your requests for Deadpool videos in the
comments below especially if you have
comic books specific videos for Deadpool
but what'll happen is I have a thor
ragnarok deleted scenes video that I'm
working on there's also some new black
panther so I'll try to post that stuff
before arrow starts tonight but new
arrow episode 2 even though this is
Deadpool stuff I'll just add the star
wars ticket giveaway to this too because
that's like the next big movie that's
coming out so all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I'll announce a
new winner when I post new Star Wars or
Marvel in the next couple of days so
while you wait for everything click here
for the Deadpool teaser trailer and you
can click here for all my Thor Ragnarok
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight